et j'aime leur un président de cette
commission spéciale sur les droits des
enfants la protection de la jeunesse
bonsoir madame laurent bonsoir de 0,1
alors si j'avais une baguette magique et
je vous dis oui à toutes vos
recommandations peuvent en parler après
en détail la beaucoup plus de prévention
une dpj plus efficace avec plus de
moyens pour les intervenants est ce que
le genre de cas horrible de graines bio
de gens auraient été évitées ça veut
dire beaucoup de choses à vous dire
qu'on serait déjà installé avec votre
baguette magique dans une société
bienveillante où tout le monde
collectivement prend soin nos enfants
qu'on fait de la prévention ce que ça
veut dire aussi c'est qu'on respecte les
droits des enfants et ces deux là la
charte des droits des enfants
ça veut dire qu'en ce moment il ya des
délais prévus dans la loi qui doivent
être respectées au stabiliser l'enfant
lui est heureuse permanence dans sa vie
empêcher les problèmes d'attachement
empêcher les les enfants de développer
des comportements qui ne sont pas
corrects et qu'on est obligé souvent de
médicaliser cette erreur dans ce que ça
voudrait dire c'est que on décide de
prendre soin de nos enfants et on décide
aussi d'accompagner les familles qui
peuvent y ait des difficultés
donc on évite des drames comme celui de
granby en principe oui voilà bon et on
évite surtout 118 signalements dont la
vaste majorité ne sont pas reconnus ça
veut dire qu'on va prendre soin de ses
enfants et de ceux de ces familles pour
qui quelqu'un lever le drapeau rouge que
vous vous mettez il ya beaucoup de
recommandations qui s'adresse en amont
du problème avant que ça arrive à la dpj
vous êtes à fait plus on va travailler
en amont - rod cas lourds à la dpg mieux
on va supporter mais votre prévention
dont vous parlez à l'école mais c est
laisser les milieux communautaires
avez vous chiffré parce que ce que vous
demandez ce qu'il ya un guichet unique
qui a plus de psychologues plus d'inde à
l'école qu'on décèle qu'une famille a
des problèmes plus appeler le celle ci
parvient rendez vous pendant deux
semaines pendant trois ans ça ça coûte
avez vous mis un chiffre là dessus je
laisse avec plaisir le gouvernement de
chiffrer mais prenons les choses
revin est ce qu'on croit vraiment qu'au
québec on a encore les moyens de
regarder la maltraitance des enfants
est-ce qu'on a encore les moyens au
québec de ne pas prendre soin des
familles qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour
la société ça veut dire des enfants qui
vont avoir des problèmes de
comportements qui vont avoir des
difficultés à l'école des familles qui
seront pas prises en charge donc ça va
se détériorer pour se retrouver ces
enfants-là aux soins intensifs que c'est
la dpj qu'est ce que c'est ce qu'on a
les moyens de faire ça ça veut dire que
on accepte de ne pas préparer les
citoyennes et citoyens de demain ça veut
dire qu'on accepte de continuer à de
forts répondre aux attentes des enfants
tout ce que les enfants veulent c'est
d'avoir quelqu'un de bienveillant de
stable des mains qui veulent l'aider à
jeux développés mais c'est gigantesque
le virage prévention que vous
recommander et est gigantesque mais
c'est du gros bon sens sapeur voir leurs
gigantesques parce que on s'est
peut-être habitués à ces deux mêmes ça
marche
non c'est juste du gros bon sens qu'on
dit c'est que il ya des familles qui
vont vu des difficultés temporaires
prenez en soin tout de suite ça va être
réglé pour vous éviter la récurrence la
maltraitance par exemple pour les
familles qui ont des grosses difficultés
il ya des programmes qui existent
pouvez-vous mais c'est probable en
application de la meilleure façon
possible selon les règles de l'art pour
accompagner ces familles
c'est ça que ça veut dire par avance a
dégénéré avant qu'on doive retirer un
livre d'une famille il ya eu 118 mille
signalement 2019 2020 c'est une
augmentation de 12 % à 35 %
d'augmentation
dupuis 2015 2016 c'est énorme le
j'arrive à après la prévention à la dpj
à la boîte de la dpj elle même
vous dites les intervenantes sont
surchargés comment on fait pour régler
ça elles sont surchargés est aussi en
souffrance elles nous l'ont dit parce
qu'elles sont surchargés parce qu'elle
n'a pas de soutien clean et parce
qu'elles n'ont pas de lieu quand elle
vit des situations très difficiles pour
être capable de vent s'il est un peu
dans ce qu'il faut pour les
intervenantes entre autres c'est mieux
les former
mieux
accompagné mieux les soutenir au niveau
clinique et c'est comme ça qu'on va être
capable de les retenir plusieurs nous
ont dit moi je vais partir parce que
j'ai personnes les plus expérimentés
n'ont pas le temps de m'accompagner
qu'angers au complexe mais gestionnaires
ils sont loin donc c'est ce soutien
clinique et aussi il faut reconnaître
que la pratique en protection de la
jeunesse la pratique avec les jeunes en
difficulté doit être reconnu comme une
pratique spécialisé est valorisée comme
tel donc ça veut dire ajustement de
salaire ça veut dire est ce que le ratio
intervenante famille doit être changé à
ce qu'on doit ce qui manque des
intervenantes
le ratio doit absolument changer et ce
qu'on dit c'est qu'au lieu d'avoir un
chiffre pour un chiffre lors que ce soit
20 22 18
il faut que la charge de cas des
intervenants soient proportionnels aux
besoins des familles il ya des familles
ou cd code est plus complexe on affaire
à peut-être plusieurs enfants alors ça
se peut pas que les le même nombre de
cas qu une autre collègue à côté ou ya
moins de cette complexité là dans les
familles alors il faut regarder à partir
des besoins qu'est ce qu'on doit donner
comme service aux familles comme tant
aux familles comme visite dans les
familles et c'est à partir de ça qu'il
faut construire pour chaque intervenant
combien de cas je mets ce que de parler
de colle à baisser leur langage
combien de quand est ce qu'on va lui
donner parce que cathay nous ont parlé
nous ont parlé de fatigue de compassion
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait avec cette
fatigue de compassion comme on l'arrêt
il faut leur permettre d'exercer selon
les règles de l'art et leur donner par
exemple d
des adjointes administratives ou lres
invitant conférence de presse ça m'a
frappé j'ai dit ça c'est pas si
compliqué mais pour nourrir des mais ça
c'est tout l'argent vous êtes combien
tout ça mais là dessus le gouvernement à
commencer par quand on parle des
adjointes administratives parce qu'on
l'avait alerté déjà le ministère dans
des rapports antérieurs et ils ont
commencé ce qu'on leur dit poursuivez
parce que c'est quand même pas normal
qu'une intervenante pas une heure et
demie parce que je dois faire coordonner
des rendez vous pour une famille c'est
quelque chose que quelqu'un d'autre peut
faire libéré ce temps là donc c'est
possible de continuer de le faire
ok rapidement vous dites nommer un
commissaire ou une commissaire à la
protection de la jeunesse
qu'est-ce que ça va changer sa
commissaire aux biens dette et aux
droits de tous les enfants du québec en
ce moment il ya personne qui est le
porte-voix de cette collectivité
d'enfants il ya personne qui fait la
promotion des droits des enfants et
c'est pour ça qu'on il faut aussi
adopter une charte des droits des
enfants
et s'il ya d'autres provinces
canadiennes qui l'ont déjà fait et on a
vu que ça a porté fruit d'avoir un
commissaire au bien-être aux droits des
enfants les enfants font plus appel à
une précieuse ans sont accueillis ceux
qui ont payé très bien oui et puis je le
rends on en a beaucoup parlé depuis
plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois mais
ce changement de loi que vous préconisez
la loi de la protection de la jeunesse
pour encourager que déplacements
deviennent permanents autrement dit oui
pour ne pas qu'un d'éveil vient dans la
famille biologique
expliquez-moi le changement que vous
voulez voir alors ce qu'il faut toujours
voir en premier c'est l'obligation de
donner tous les services à la famille
biologique ça il faut que ce soit clair
maintenant une fois que avec les délais
prévus dans la loi on se rend compte que
ce ne sera pas possible que l'enfant
retourne dans sa famille biologique
il faut arrêter les essayera et le dpj
doit aller devant un juge et déclaré cet
enfant lors apte à l'adoption où
l'enfant est sous tutelle s'appelle dans
la famille élargie et on propose même
qui a une nouvelle forme d'adoption où
l'enfant n'est pas obligé de couper les
liens sur ce terrain
ils ont dit ça existe ailleurs et par
exemple c'est des communautés
autochtones
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'adoption
coutumière l'enfance et qui sont s'est
pas séparé mer mais l'autorité parentale
est transféré à quelqu'un d'autre et
l'enfant sait qu'il est dense et
stabilité là qui a sept adultes
bienveillant qui vont être là tout le
long de sa vie c'est ce dont l'enfant a
besoin de stabilité de permanence et
d'avoir une sécurité affective et les
jeudis à des gens qui nous l'ont dit moi
j'aurais été content puis ma famille
d'accueil relève adopté mais vous m'avez
demandé à me demander de renier mes
parents c'est comme ça que les jeunes le
voient alors on comprend le déchirement
il ya moyen de faire autrement et c'est
une des propositions qu'on fait très
intéressant cette proposition l'adoption
simple on va reparler manable orange
book labo quand même tout ça ne sera pas
possible j'ai pas tout ça sera possible
sur un investissement
quand même assez important on va se le
dire il ya un investissement mais il ya
quelque chose aussi
ça veut dire un changement de culture ça
veut et cela ça prend du temps ça prend
beaucoup de volonté le changement que ce
alors ça aussi c'est très important
régine laurent président de la
commission spéciale sur les droits des
enfants la protection de la jeunesse on
va en reparler